hi there how are you hi i'm good how are
you doing i am doing very well thank you
for talking to me i appreciate it very
much my pleasure
and i know it's off topic but
congratulations on your son winning a
tony award because that's just cool so i
just had to say that no that was pretty
amazing you know
it's it's nice that theater is back and
i'm sure you are proud of him for his
work so
oh yeah yeah well we just like to see
him working yeah
he was off for a year
yeah there when the theater shut down
that was it that was his career
he was finished for a year now it's all
coming back he's working on beetlejuice
too which is coming back in april
yeah so
yeah well that is definitely a way to
get back to work just kick it off with
an award so
win the tony award he's pretty nice
we're proud of him
do you consider it a personal triumph
yourself
for how many children you have freaked
out over the years is that sort of a
badge of honor that you wear probably
if i was being facetious i would agree
with you
and say yes i'm certainly i'm that's my
job is to scare kids right
but if i was to give you a serious
answer i'd say i'm i'm more proud of the
kids who learned to read on my books
and the kids who um
didn't like to read and then discovered
my books and then did like to read
now that's sort of the whole point of
the thing
but i do like scaring them
you're definitely quite a prolific
writer and it's fair to say that there
are a lot of people who have read your
books
so
did you always want your books and
stories to be turned into tv shows and
films was that something that you had
thought about at all was it something
you weren't necessarily concerned with
when you've been writing them
it was something i was not necessarily
thinking about
when i was writing let's say where i was
writing fear street or writing
goosebumps you know i'm an author i'm
here in new york i'm not out in la i'm
in new york and i'm i'm like being in my
room writing not collaborating writing
books and you don't you know i don't
think you really think about it and then
people come to you and then it's you
know you have it look it took 23 years
for them to make the goosebumps movie
goosebumps been been around 23 years
before they finally got the movie out
so if i'd been worried about it for the
whole time that would have been terrible
right
yeah i've been thinking about it
so when people come to you and they say
oh we'd like to make a movie of your
work you say
oh great and then you say oh great
i always have this those two reactions
because for one thing you don't know if
it's going to be any good it could be
horrible yeah right
i've been so lucky and that all the
adaptations for my stuff has been really
good
the goosebumps movies were good and this
just beyond series
um
it's i think it's wonderful i'm just
lucky that way
what has the experience been like for
you to
see them come together
obviously each one feels like it would
be a very different experience
are you
good with watching them and seeing them
as separate
you know entities from your own work
yeah i am
i it's kind of fun i think to see if
somebody takes your story and goes off
in their direction with it it's fun to
see what they do with your story
i really enjoy that part i do i think
some authors probably hate it
but i enjoy it and of course it's always
great when people come to you and say oh
your book was much better
i love that too
how did this series come about it was
this did it surprise you that somebody
wanted to take this on especially with
the sort of anthology nature of it or
how did this how did you hear that they
were going to be yeah
yeah i was surprised i had you know i
had never written any graphic novels
i've done everything
but i've never done any graphic novels
and i ran into an editor from boom
studios
at comic-con san diego the last one you
could go to
and a couple years ago
and he's we started talking about how
he'd never done graphic novels and he
said oh we should try something
and we came up with the name just beyond
you know just beyond reality
just beyond the normal world and um he
signed me up i wrote four of them
the fourth one comes out next month it's
called monstrosity
and that's how the that's how the
graphic novels got started and then they
went to seth graham smith and said take
a look at this graphic novel is this
something you would like to adapt for
television
what do you like about the approach that
he took with these stories and
translating them i just i i love how the
series is done i think
they each create their own world which
is so fun
yeah i like the variety of it i'm a big
twilight zone fan
rod thirling is a big hero of mine and i
love those shows and this has that
twilight zone feel to it and i like that
there's a supernatural one there's a
fantasy one there's an alternate
universe one
there's supernatural
i i like that a lot that you you get all
those things that they did on the
twilight zone yeah
[Music]
there's also such a great cast
throughout the series there's a lot of
new faces there's a lot of young actors
what's it like for you to see how all of
these actors took this material on
well they were so good
they're all these young actors were
terrific
and they didn't have much time to work
you know they filmed
eight of them i think they had two maybe
three weeks two weeks
to film each episode and it was during
the pandemic
which makes it you know even tougher and
the performances are just terrific i
think
what's it like for you to see your
characters visualize in that way i mean
do you picture anyone in particular when
you're writing characters or
is it just kind of strange to see
a character that you wrote brought to
life for real well i'm used to it now
so it's not you know it isn't strange
when i write i try to picture kids that
are the age of who i'm writing for
so if i'm writing a teen book a ya book
a fear street i have
teen faces in my mind and i try to
picture them as teenagers and then when
i'm writing for younger kids i i picture
younger kids but that's about as far as
i go i'm not that visual a person really
are there tricks to making fantasy and
horror work as family entertainment when
you do
material like this do you have a gauge
for how far you can go when it comes to
the scares
well i have a gauge like for fear street
books i have one solid rule that i
always stick to for this 7 to 12 age
group
and that is they have to know that the
story couldn't happen
they have to know it's a fantasy
it couldn't really happen in real life
and when you establish that then you can
go pretty far with the scares
fear street did really well i mean those
movies i i loved them my co-workers all
loved them we talked about them a lot
what is it like to see the success of
that the reaction to that how has it
been to hear people talking about
what they thought of those movies
the whole thing was a shock to me
i've never done anything r-rated before
in my life i say my even my life isn't
r-rated never
never and then to have these three
r-rated films are so violent we sure
killed off a lot of teenagers
didn't we we killed a lot and i just um
so that was kind of a surprise to me
that they wanted to do it in that way
but um i'm so glad they they did them so
well
yeah i i thought
lee janiak just
amazing director she was just
did just a masterful job with them i
think
yeah i mean just the the way the gore
was approached for that i thought there
were some really just creative and
imaginative things that were done with
it that i haven't seen before which
doesn't happen too often these days
there's only so many ways you can kill a
person so
yeah with an axe yeah
not too many ways
yeah i thought it was really fun
anyway i was amazed by that and by the
success all three films were number one
on netflix it was unbelievable i'm
having a great year you know i'm pretty
much
you've said that your stories are a
combination of humor and fear why has
that always been a good combination for
you why do you like to add humor to that
you know the secret is i the secret is i
never um
i never planned to be scary
i never wanted that wasn't my goal i
always was funny
i did a humor magazine for 10 teenagers
for 10 years called bananas and i wrote
about 100 joke books
i'm always funny
and so when i
got switched over which is sort of a
long story and started being a scary guy
i brought i had to bring the humor with
me because that's my main interest
really
you've said too that the scary stuff
doesn't scare you so when did you
realize that i mean was it reading scary
books was it watching scary movies and
not having the same reaction that other
people have those people coming to me
and saying after i read your book i had
to leave all the lights on and i locked
all the doors and i and i thought gee
i've never had that feeling from
anything
i've never had it it's just something
missing in me i think
what were the stories that most inspired
you as a kid what did what do you think
had the biggest influence on your
writing
um
well a lot of things i think a lot but
um when i was a kid there were these
scary comic books these horror comics
called tales from the crypt and the
vault of horror and they were very very
influential on me they were
gory gruesome
horror stories with brilliant art and
they all had a funny twist ending every
story had a funny twist at the end and
it's sort of that sort of it's what i
try to do
do you have other adaptations that are
currently in development or in the works
now do you know like what the next thing
based on your work could be
um
well i don't know if i can talk about
them
i don't know there's a you know i did
these four books um
y.a books called the babysitter
yeah about this girl and i think they're
being developed
the babysitter books
but i'm probably not allowed to talk
about it
okay
i think there's another goosebumps tv
series in the works but i haven't heard
much about that
where do you go to for inspiration now
are there things that you turn to like
if you're between writing something and
you want to get inspiration from
somewhere between when am i
i'm never between
that's a problem i didn't know if you
ever need a refresher
no i don't know i read i i read all the
time i'm a very big reader i read every
day and i but i read mostly thrillers
and mysteries
i like old british mysteries i've been
reading perry mason mysteries from the
40s
earl stanley gardner he's great
i i read that i
i don't know where i i just
have to use my own brain for inspiration
i think
and keep going
you previously said you started writing
when you were nine years old
how does it feel to still be doing it
all these years later and to see how
relevant your work still is yeah i mean
what's wrong with me why do i still like
it
most people know when to quit right i
mean clearly you chose the right thing
yeah obviously i'm cut out i've never
done anything else
never had a real job
but um i i just love it i don't know i i
and now especially during these hard
times and during the past couple years
when i sit down in the morning to write
it was like a bit of normal life for me
it was like you know my lifestyle hadn't
changed i have a couple hours of writing
every day it's sort of the best part of
my day
yeah i totally understand that i mean
aside from
you know doing these kind of things
where i just talk to people through a
computer now it is uh
it's it there's you kind of don't have
to skip a beat when you can just keep
writing the same way that you were yeah
no it's true
well i appreciate you talking to me i
love the show i love your work
oh thank you thank you christina and i
love the adaptations which you can't
always say so i appreciate all of that
thank you so much
that's great my pleasure